hinter jener 2020 11 uhr in der wiener
hofburg die erste türkis grüne
bundesregierung in österreich wird vom
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
angelobt neben bundeskanzler sebastian
kurz von der vp und vize kanzler werner
kogler von den grünen werden 14
ministerinnen und minister vereidigt
unter ihnen die erste
verteidigungsministerin der republik
klaudia tanner von der vp bei der
amtsübergabe am nachmittag im
verteidigungsministerium in wien bedankt
sich der scheidende
verteidigungsminister thomas
schmollinger die neue
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
wirbt bei ihrer antrittsrede und
vertrauen
[Musik]